bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du statut de culture et
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
20 juin la ferme de bel ébat innove pour
sa saison 2018-2019 d'être guyancourt
toi lance un projet autour du patrimoine
l'héritage culturel des mers son
directeur nous a reçus et versailles
fait renaître jean cot elle la peinture
le peintre du roi louis xiv était un peu
oublié plusieurs de ses oeuvres sont
exposées au trianon et ont même inspiré
les jardiniers du château et l'harmonie
de 50 ans les vignes vous invite à fêter
l'été
ce mardi 26 juin les 40 musiciens
joueront notamment de la musique de film
le patrimoine c'est un mot qu'on connaît
peu il va pourtant rythme et la saison
de la ferme de bel ébat présentation de
l'année 2018 2019 du théâtre de
guyancourt nicolas kirillovitch et
sandrine frontale pour les moyens
techniques
[Musique]
et
une année féminine voici le credo de la
prochaine saison de la ferme de bel ébat
de guyancourt auprès de 80 dates
proposées
allons à la rencontre du directeur pour
en savoir un peu plus
[Musique]
yoann lavabre bonjour bonjour
alors cette année la ferme innove avec
un projet autour du matrimoine avec or
en rêvant matrimoine tout à fait le
matrimoine c'est un mot étrange parce
que c'est un mot qui sonne comme un
néologisme alors que en réalité c'est un
mot très anciens on parlait au moyen-age
on avait le patrimoine c'est est-ce que
ce que le ce que le mari a mené aux
ménages et le matrimoine c'est est-ce
que ce que la femme à porter on n'a
gardé que le mot patrimoine en a
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui des journées
européennes du patrimoine d'un côté et
puis des agences matrimoniales de
l'autre ça en dit beaucoup sur sur la la
la façon dont les mots qu'on utilise
enfin est-ce que c'est ce que s'exprime
le matrimoine donc c'est en fait c'est
l'héritage et l'héritage des mères c'est
ce qui nous vient des femmes à travers
l'histoire donc la ferme de bel ébat
effectivement s'engage pour la saison
prochaine et les quatre suivantes 1
c'est un grand un grand projet à
valoriser cet héritage artistique et
culturelle féminin tant dans le domaine
du théâtre que dans le domaine de la
musique
donc on va favoriser la programmation de
pièces écrites par des femmes au 17e 18e
19e siècle pareil pour la musique avec
des femmes aussi sur scène il n'y en a
pas mal oui c'est que la ferme de bel
bat s'est engagé depuis 2012 dans une
programmation paritaire afin de
respecter l'équilibré entre les femmes
et les hommes dans la création
artistique
hélas le matrimoine c'est allez encore
un petit peu au-delà si elle s'est un
peu plonger dans les racines de
l'histoire du théâtre pour pour ré
offrir une légitimité aux femmes
artistes d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est
ce qui manque un petit peu on ne connaît
pas les autres is des siècles passés
et pourtant ce sont de très belles
plumes je rappelle pendant que le
favori de madame de villedieu qui va
ouvrir le ce cycle sur le matrimoine qui
a été créé à la ferme de bel ébat en
voilà c'est une pièce que nous reprenons
et cette pièce a été mise en scène en
1665 par un homme qui n'est pas tout à
fait un inconnu dans l'histoire du
théâtre puisque cet homme s'appelait
molière de la molière avait monté le sa
venue de madame de villedieu et la pièce
avait joué à versailles pratiquement à
l'inauguration de versailles devant
louis xiv
donc ces pièces étaient tout à fait à
l'honneur à l'époque elles sont
aujourd'hui oubliées et on a on a pour
ambition de les faire re découvrir
comment le théâtre d'un cabaret ce
discours
si je partage votre vie
pour moi il ya un autre maître mot
auquel tient la ferme de bel ébat c'est
la création vous en est pas moins de 27
à peu près cette année oublie cette
année pratiquement une pièce sur deux
est une création alors c'est à dire une
pièce que nous avons décidé de
programmer avant de l'avoir vu
c'est une façon pour nous important de
faire confiance aux artistes
au moment où ils ont le plus besoin de
nous c'est à dire que si on attend
toujours d'avoir vu le spectacle pour le
programme et il n'y a pas de possibilité
pour que le spectacle existe donc voila
nous ont fait le pari de la création et
de la confiance aux artistes et cette
confiance passe aussi par des nouvelles
résidences
c'est un renouveau on repart sur un
cycle de kia or en revanche on a parlé
tout à l'heure
pascal antonini et isabelle olivier tout
à fait on avait classique de trois ans
avec aurélie van den dalle godefroy
ségal et praliné gay-para qui je
voudrais profiter de ce temps pour
rendre hommage à un travail formidable
qu'ils ont fait pendant trois ans mais
là une page se tourne une nouvelle
s'écrient avec ces trois artistes très
complémentaires donc aux aurores pour le
projet matrimoine pascal antonini qui
lui est metteur en scène un homme de
théâtre vraiment pascal sans heurt
occurrence oui et isabelle olivier qui
et harpiste et compositrice de jazz est
là c'est une résidence a soutenu par le
ministère de la culture et la sacem de
deux années de résidence autour de son
répertoire et c'est l'arbre qui va
commencer parce que vos premières dates
c'est les 8 et 11 septembre et 7
isabelle olivier qui va sortir
il valait la rencontre des gens on va
retrouver isabelle dans énormément de
projets des concerts des actions avec
les habitants des ateliers et puis
effectivement ce petit récital auquel
vous faites allusion potable à tommy
c'est un récital hors les murs qui
jouera sous un tipi indien à la
rencontre des publics les plus variés on
retrouvera donc la harpe au forum des
associations à la brocante du pont du
rotois re et tout au long de la saison
d'autres circonstances a faim on va dire
d'apporter la musique auprès des publics
qui peut être ne viendrait pas
spontanément l'écouté au théâtre
or il ya plus de 80 dates dans votre
saison
parmi celles ci il y a notamment j'ai
rencontré dieu sur facebook d'ahmed
madani c'est les 8 et 9 novembre pour
votre salle
pourquoi ce spectacle sous du mans on
accueillera ahmed ahmed madani qui est
un roman un des grands artistes de la
scène contemporaine et il viendra en
résidence de création dont il répétera
ici pendant un peu plus de deux semaines
afin de faire jouer son spectacle c'est
cette toute nouvelle pièce c'est une
caisse qui aborde un sujet important
puisqu'il s'agit de la radicalisation
islamiste
une jeune adolescente via les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est fait avec beaucoup de
tendresse beaucoup d'humour voilà madani
et un est un auteur extrêmement fins
extrêmement subtile qui connaît qui
connaît bien aussi le sujet de la
jeunesse le sujet de la banlieue et je
précise que l'on retrouvera également
ahmed à la scène nationale
enola c'est un artiste pour c'est une
compagnie à rayonnement international
qu'accompagné d'haman mana ni et donc il
jouera flamme qu'il a déjà joué avec les
bas à la scène nationale le même mois il
ya un spectacle c'est qui vous tient à
coeur de david gauchard placer le 14 mai
alors on part un peu plus loin dans la
saison
je fonctionne le fils voilà c'est un
petit peu le pendant c'est à dire
qu'avec avec j'ai rencontré dieu sur
facebook on aborde la question de la
radicalisation islamiste mais il faut
pas oublier que c'est pas c'est pas la
seule radicalisation qui existe est le
fils est un est un très très beau
spectacle de david gauchard qui raconte
le parcours d'une femme qui elle alors
on parle pas de radicalisation mais on
veut dire qu elle s'engouffre un peu
dans le militantisme de l'intégrisme
catholique
c'est une femme notamment qui qui va un
peu s'exalter ce passionné dans la lutte
contre le mariage pour tous jusqu'au
moment où elle découvrira qu un de ses
fils est homosexuel et ce sera un grand
tournant dans sa vie c'est un très très
beau spectacle
on ferait un débat avec l'école des
parents à l'issue de la représentation
sur sur ces questions est sensible
délicate et david gauchard est également
artiste associé à la scène nationale de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est comme ça on se retrouve parfois
sans avoir forcément chercher c'est
comme ça sont des bons signes sont des
thèmes d'actualité parfois un peu dur
mais il ya un public que vous n'oubliez
jamais chaque année c'est l'enfance la
jeunesse
on leur parle à eux aussi oui oui
beaucoup de spectacle alors là ce sont
des spectacles qui s'adresse à la
jeunesse mais pas à l'enfant sain pour
le coup parce que les sujets sont graves
mais les adolescents représentent une
part importante du public à travers
notamment les établissements scolaires
les lycées les collèges avec lesquels
nous travaillons
et puis voilà une grosse programmation
pour l'enfance à partir de 2 ans dans
tous les genres on va trouver de la
danse pour les tout petits avec un un
petit coin de ciel ou la nouvelle
création des frères benhaim mirage les
zones boréales
mais également de la marionnette du
conte du théâtre et de la musique pour
pour nos plus jeunes spectateurs
[Musique]
une programmation
merci fils yoann lavabre alors pour ne
rien rater de cette saison rendez vous
sur le site kiosque point ski point fr
c'est un peintre un peu oublié mais jean
cot elle a marqué son art et son époque
le peintre travailler pour le roi louis
xiv ou pour monsieur le frère du
monarque
le château lui consacre une exposition
au grand trianon
plus d'une vingtaine de ses tableaux
sont rassemblés et l'un d'entre eux a
même inspiré les jardiniers du château
camille lambert pour les images un
bosquet tout en illusions en son centre
jean cau taille pas un nombre un peu
irréel un ensemble le vrai le faux ce
que toi
ce bosquet du marais aujourd'hui disparu
donc c'est un témoignage très
intéressant de ses bosquets de je dirais
du appartenant au versailles baroque le
premier versailles celui de madame de
montespan et d'ailleurs il est dit que
ce bosquet à l'origine madame de
montespan l'avait imaginé c'est l'un des
21 tableaux de jean cot elles
rassemblées par le château de versailles
l'artiste du roi aimé peindre jardin et
mythologie des tableaux restaurés
pendant 5 à 6 ans dont 16 de manière
fondamentale exposé aujourd'hui dans
l'un des lieux les plus prestigieux du
trianon la galerie dicko tél
c'est un lieu ouvert sur l'extérieur par
des fenêtres du côté des parterres et du
cade côté des jeux du jardin des sources
c'est un lieu où la lumière pénètre est
en quelque sorte les tableaux de
bosquets que vous voyez ici reflète cet
extérieur le roi aimait se promener dans
ses jardins y faire des haltes et de
nouveau à l'intérieur il se repose
devant ses bosquets jean cotten des
jardins et des dieux celui aussi à
l'extérieur le miniaturiste a inspiré
les jardiniers du château une longue
étude de ce tableau pour recréer la
volonté du peintre plus d'une vingtaine
de variétés de plantes donne vie ce
tableau
près d'une trentaine d'oeuvres font
revivre à l'artiste mobilier comme une
renaissance
[Musique]
vendredi dernier il répétait dans
l'écrin de l'orangerie du château de
versailles
ils ce sont les jeunes chinois musiciens
de l'orchestré demos le dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale
le 23 juin ils seront sur la scène de la
cité de la musique le fruit d'un travail
de pros de deux ans on écoute nawal
roger la coordinatrice de location des
yvelines elle et aux microbes grégory
qu'à l'aller c'est un peu la fête c'est
l'aboutissement aussi de beaucoup de
travail puisque il travaille comme je
voulais dit deux fois par semaine y en a
qui révise aussi chez eux
et là c'est un moment de grande joie et
aussi de grande fierté de pouvoir
montrer le travail à leurs parents à
leur famille aux élus de leur ville qui
se déplace et qui viennent les applaudir
fêter l'été en musique même après le 21
juin l'harmonie de saint quentin en
yvelines vous invite à son concert
annuel 40 musiciens sur scène le 26 juin
prochain avec tout un programme et pour
en parler le président de l'association
roland simon et deux des musiciens jules
brunel et jean françois robin bonjour à
tous les trois jours
alors le rendez vous approche un peu
moins d'une semaine est ce que tout le
monde est prêt farré peine dur voilà
bien répéter demain pour la fête de la
musique on va faire ce qu'on peut
appeler une générale donc on va on va
jouer ce qu'on jouera mardi prochain
même si on a je pense qu'on aura
quelques absents de par le fait que l'on
me sens mieux je dis la fête la musique
puis
du travail bon c'est pas toujours
évident mais bon jusqu'à présent pour ce
concert vous allez jouer des musiques de
film jules brunel c'est
et pourquoi la musique de chaînes déjà
c'est surtout pour ouvrir un petit peu
plus au public puisque il y en a qui
peuvent être touchées par certaines
musiques de film et je rejoins ses
morceaux cela pourrait au moins
permettent de plaire au public et
surtout essayer de découvrir des
musiques qui ne sont pas forcément des
musiques du film ça peut aussi aller
vers le classique et vers des chansons
un peu plus moderne
jean françois robin est ce que la
musique de film est un genre qui
correspond à votre art monnaies puisque
vous êtes déjà vous jouez tous des
instruments avant tout à fait d'ailleurs
nous sommes bien représentés un
trompettiste un saxophoniste
clarinettiste bas les musiques de films
sont souvent des films un petit peu
voilà pêchue on peut le dire et donc il
ya des cuivres notamment et puis les
arrangements avec des flûtes des carrés
nets des bois est donc tout à fait c'est
tout à fait adapté et puis il est de
toute façon des orchestrations fait pour
les harmonies en fait est souvent comme
c'est des thèmes assez connu aussi ça
marche très bien auprès du public et
donc tout le monde est content voilà on
va écouter un extrait ce que c'est pas
la première fois que j'allais jouer de
la musique alors là ça date un petit peu
ça de 2012 mais ça donne un avant-goût
écouter
[Musique]
le
alors les cinéphiles auront sans doute
reconnu pirates des caraïbes est ce
qu'on pourra l'entendre le 26 juin
non ah non cette année cette année
habituellement l'harmonie a un gros
programme de musiques de film et cette
année mal en fin malheureusement pas
malheureusement
on a changé un tout petit peu parce que
nous avons tenté un concours national
qui est un lieu le 3 juin exactement à
saint pierre des corps qui se trouve à
côté de tours et pour ce faire nous
avons donc préparé au cours de l'année
trois pièces exclusives pour le concours
dédié au concours qu'on va entendre
alors qu'est ce qu'on entendait alors un
de ses joueurs le 26 juin on va entendre
une
une musique de fantaisie latin fantasy
qui s'appelle el camino real un extrait
de la belle et la bête et l'on revient
sur disney et donc visite de films bien
sûr ensuite trois morceaux que nous
avons joué pour le concours qui sont
norvégien rand'eau les voyages de
gulliver donc en 4 4 parties et puis
alors de whisky jack c'est adam ce
plutôt très chaude à l'irlande est
compliqué alors il aidé c'est un peu
compliqué parce que justement un rôle en
a parlé du concours faut quand même dire
que nous avons gagné le premier prix de
ce concours dans la première division
dans notre catégorie
et effectivement ce sont des des
morceaux tout à fait intéressant est
jolie mais avec beaucoup de travail
puisque certains d'entre eux figurait
justement programme du concours
voilà alors chaque année vous n'êtes pas
seul sur la scène vous ouvrez votre
concert avec des invités cette année
c'est le monde orchestre a alors le
montini one ochestra en fait c'est long
only conservateur de montigny le
bretonneux qui a été renommé montini
wind orchestra depuis l'année dernière
donc avant y'avait pas de nom et donc en
fait c'est historique c'est historique
dans le sens où le
landry de saint quentin en yvelines a
été fondée par il ya vingt ans
maintenant par des professeurs du
conservatoire de montigny donc française
par la mort d'une autre chef faisait
partie et puis après pour des raisons
divergentes dire de deux points de vue
orchestre l'orchestra à dix on dise on
s'est séparés des conservatoires en fait
zéro on est indépendant si vous l'avez
dit 20 ans cette année
oui assure la saison 2010 et 2019 soit
plutôt sur 19 18 19
c'est ça comment est-ce qu'on prépare
ses 20 ans vous avez une grosse très
grosse saison
alors la saison il y aura un gros point
fort de la saison ce sera à la mi mai où
on organise un festival des harmonies
qui sera le 18 et 19 donc que deux après
midi où il y aura quatre à cinq
harmonies qui vont jouer successivement
et le samedi soir un concert par une
requête qui n'est pas encore choisi
voilà le temps de préparer ça et puis
bien sûr le concert de fin d'année
toujours à montigny avec le wind
orchestra
on est un peu pris par le temps que
malheureusement mais merci que les trois
d'être venu en plateau alors le concert
celui du 26 juin pas celui de l'année
prochaine c'est à 20h à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny le bretonneux
foncé par contre à réserver alors là on
va parler concert rock rock et
philosophique parce que ça se passait à
l'espace yves montand depuis quand de
guyancourt rock'n philo est née dans
l'esprit d'un professeur de philosophie
musiciens et après un ouvrage il en a
fait un concert regardez là aussi la
démarche de voltaire de la douleur
donald young est la même dans la chanson
de la viande
on fait le constat empirique du mal qui
existe voilà un mariage qu'elle on
n'aurait pas pensé
voltaire et neil young partage de même
idée dans candide et rocking in the free
world
à la guitare francis métivier professeur
de philosophie amateurs de rock'n'roll
et créateur du rock'n philo ça remonte à
l'adolescence en fait
j'ai découvert la fois le rock et la
philosophie en prenant conscience au
fond que les deux avaient des messages
pas des questionnements et des messages
à peu près équivalent évidemment exprimé
dans des formes très très différentes
mais il ya un point commun qui est le
côté un peu contestataire la remise en
cause de l'ordre établi que ce soit chez
socrate en philosophie par exemple ou
chez dylan dans le domaine de la folk
song après un premier ouvrage du même
nom en 2011
francis métivier prend sa guitare et
monte sur scène accompagné de christian
jeantet et philippe du janerand
[Musique]
ma gueule qui va me permet d'expliquer
la liberté chez sartre enfin le regard
de l'autre qui me prive de ma liberté
c'est un questionnement qui
intéresserait les gens parce que c'est
vraiment un thème philosophique et rock
1 les deux faces est pas le seul à
ignorer le désirent y aurait l'amour y
aurait plein l'histoire sûrs plein de
choses les spectateurs n'ont pas eu de
copie à rendre à l'issue de secours
concert et en goûter à la liberté
[Musique]
un rendez vous cinéma ne pas rater c'est
celui de bertrand pin et des yeux della
d'elza à saint-cyr-l'ecole regarder le
coup de coeur du cinéma les yeux d'elsa
cette semaine c'est le festival les
images vagabonde 7e édition du festival
organisé par contre chant l'association
contrechamp qui agit dans le vexin
français un peu partout dans les
yvelines qui développe son festival dans
des bibliothèques chez l'habitant mais
aussi dans des cinémas et donc nous on
accueillera le dimanche 1er juillet deux
projections une projection de wall-e le
petit robot de pixar
certains d'entre vous se souviennent
forcément qui sera accompagné d'un
atelier fabrique ton robots en carton le
robot on ne fabrique pas des vrais
robots et puis à 18 heures j'aurai le
plaisir de vous présenter le film
paprika de satoshi kon un des monuments
du cinéma d'animation japonais plutôt
pour adulte celui là ces deux films ont
la particularité d'essayer de vous faire
rentrer dans des mondes imaginaires et
c'est toute la thématique du festival
de contrechamp les images vagabonde que
vous pourrez retrouver partout dans le
territoire du 16 juin au 13 juillet
voilà à très bientôt au cinéma les yeux
d'elsa bécassiers n'est peut-être pas
notre cousine mais elle a rythmé
l'enfance de plusieurs d'entre nous la
jeune fille naïve et maladroite et
l'héroïne du dernier film du versailles
et bruno podalydès
il était de retour dans sa ville natale
ce week-end pour le présenter regarde
[Musique]
une robe verte et une coiffe blanche
reconnaissable
revoilà bécassine la bigoudène est
remise au goût du jour le versailles et
bruno podalydès créé sa nounou 2018
toujours naïve et empoté ceni des drôles
donc la seconde relie démunis des drôles
de bécassine est là elle a quelque chose
de
je le redis d'ajustement
on lui reproche beaucoup de choses à
cette bécassine alors c'est une jeune
femme de papier très attachante j'ai
appris à la découvrir en écrivant de
films et jeux
la fois drôle et émouvante c'est un beau
cocktail web au sein des classes i
bonjour madeleine bonjour mademoiselle
sa tête
on a vu passer trois nourrissons un mois
alors attention mademoiselle bécassine
là c'est l'heure du biberon c'est
automatique le réalisateur du mystère de
la chambre jaune et le parfum de la dame
en noir s'initier son huitième long
métrage où il mélange gags originaux et
nouvelle invention avec au casting karin
viard denis podalydès
emeline bayart j'avais vu que cette
actrice était extraordinaire et méconnus
comme un peu comme bécassine et du coup
j'ai superposant les sur le visage des
mille et des cents bécassine j'ai vu un
film possible
j'ai écrit en porte en elle le film a
suscité la colère d'un mouvement
indépendantiste breton mais cette
deuxième adaptation est à découvrir dans
les salles dès ce mercredi 20 juin c'est
urgent je reviens monsieur rasta claque
hausse madame la marquise prince akoulov
à l'appareil
[Musique]
demain jeudi 21 juin c'est la fête de la
musique et les instruments vont résonner
un peu partout dans les yvelines à
versailles rendez vous dès 19 heures au
quartier notre dame le quartier saint
louis ou encore la place de l'europe à
plaisir il faut voir il faudra vous
rendre au parc de l'hôtel de ville à
magny-les-hameaux direction la maison de
l'environnement
par contre là c'est le 23 juin et à
montigny-le-bretonneux maurepas et
voisins-le-bretonneux eux ne sont pas en
reste c'est le 21 juin à juillan tôt à
guyancourt ça se passe à la batterie le
samedi déplairait des plaisirs wav on
s'insurge et en poésie des écoliers
collégiens et adultes de la commune se
rassemblent devant l'école rabelais de
la commune autour de yves godin fait la
fin de ce statut de culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi
prochain
[Musique]